لاول مره منذ 3,200 عام وبتعاون المصريه
انجليزي تمكن فريق من العلماء من اعاده
بناء وجه احد اقوى ملوك مصر القديمه الملك
رمسيس الثاني هي اول اعاده بناء عمليه
للوجه بناء على فحص بالاشعه المقطعيه
لجمجومته الفعليه وباستخدام نموذج ثلاثي
الابعاد لاعاده بناء ملامحه وهي عمليه
دقيقه جدا وبعد ما ظهرت صوره الملك في
شيخوخه حيث يعتقد انه عاشر 90 عاما عادوا
الزمن الى الوراء نصف قرن تحديدا ومن
الشيخوخه الى الشباب تمكنوا من الكشف عن
وجهه في ذروه» رمسيس الثاني ثالث ملوك
الاسره التاسعه عشر في مصر القديمه اكتسب
شهرته الخالده من تماثيره الضخمه التي
اشرف على تنفيذها اعتلى العرش وهو في
الخامسه والعشرين من عمره وحكم البلاد
لنحو 67 عاما
[موسيقى]
اول عمليه علميه لاعاده بناء وجه لاول مره
تتم هذه المره لاقوى ملوك مصر رمسيس
الثاني حدثيني عن التقنيه اولا التي كشفت
ملامح رمسيس في شبابه والاعاده ترتيب
واعاده بناء هذه الملابس كيف تمت الطريقه
العلوم واستخدامها في الاثار اعطت بعدا
كبيرا للاثار واعطت مصداقيه كبيره ومن ضمن
هذه العلوم امم علم الاشعه هو استخدامه في
تصوير الموميات
هي اجساد
عاشت يعني لالام سنين بفضل عمليه التحنيط
سحر اللافت في المساله بان كل عناوين
الصحف وايضا عن ناوين مواقع التواصل تصدرت
بانه رمسيس جميل وجميل جدا هل هذا الوصف
فعلا بانه
ظهر كاجميل الملامح ام بان الصوره واضحه
هذه المره عندما نتحدث عن مومياء عمرها
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف عام برزت بوضوح اليوم
العمليه عمليه علميه
والملامح كما تريناها نسبه همم صدقها نسبه
عاليه جدا
وباستخدام المقاسات الوجوه المصريه يعني
ولكن همم
الملك الوسيم هذا هو كان تعبيري وهذا هو
كان ردد فعلي
عندما
اشتركت في
بناء وجه الملك فظهر بملامح مصريه
نبيله وسيمه
كما يعني نجدها في في شوارع بلادنا
فبهذا الوصف هو وصف دقيق
ونتج منه ملامح مصريه وهو بيحد ذاته همم
نوع من انواع النجاح طيب الدكتوره دكتوره
المعروف انه يعتقل بالاحرى انه رمسيس
الثاني توفي كان عمره 90 عاما انتم رجعتم
بالزمن نحو نصف قرن اظهرت ملامحه شاب كيف
حصل ذلك
التقنيه هي تركيب وجهها باستخدام
الكمبيوتر على مجسم ثلاثي الابعاد للجمجمه
بوجود المكتبه الرقميه
في الكمبيوتر
والمقاسات العضلات المختلفه محفوظه في هذه
المكتبه وبا يعني تقنيات عاليه جدا يتم
تركيبها ديجيتلي على الكمبيوتر وبالتالي
ممكن ان احنا نشوفه في سن الذي توفي فيه
ال90 عاما ونرجع
بالزمان الى الوراء باعطاء نضاره اكثر
للعضلات فيبدوا وهو في قمه مجده العسكري
[موسيقى]